so you've been on these stages you've
been when the ryman auditorium is sold
out
you've been in front of massive festival
crowds
tell everybody what it looks like when
you quote unquote make it right
your bank account suddenly fill up you
suddenly are able to see yourself in a
new light your marriage is great you're
super parent like
help people deconstruct that fantasy yes
i i made the mistake
uh when i got to play carnegie hall
with stephen curtis chapman who had when
i was a kid was like my idol
right i had a poster of him on my wall
when i was 12. so i got to play
i was in his band we played carnegie
hall the first time for him
and i made the mistake of checking my
bank account right before i walked on
stage because i was holding my phone
just
like oh oh that's not the right color
i didn't magically just deposit in when
you no no
um and uh yes you know the thing is is
that
when i finally stepped away from my
career in music i was able to look at it
i mean i still do it but when i when i
stepped away for the first time thinking
i was done
when i was 35 i could and i you know
could write it out on paper i went oh
that looks like a guy who's done some
stuff
but every day of that 16 years that i
was full-time doing that
just felt like a failure every day felt
like
yeah i'm i'm i'm pretty good but there's
that guy
but i didn't get that gig but that guy
got that gig would there ever be a place
is there any musicians any artists that
are like
nah i'm here i i i personally exist
there's a there's a
one of the phrases that goes around
guitar players is
john mayer wants to be eric clapton eric
clapton wants to be george harrison
george harrison wants to be paul
mccartney and paul mccartney wants to be
paul mccartney in 1964.
all right which is basically john mayer
meaning that it doesn't matter you're
always always somebody better
there's always somebody that you that
you wish you were
when when that's what you operate out of
you will never crest the wave
and so walk somebody through walking off
that stage
it because most of us will never walk on
stage at carnegie hall
right you play a show with your idol
on a stage that is magical
you step off you take off your leather
pants because clearly let's be honest
and then you go backstage you shower you
go home and you're in a hotel room by
yourself
yeah that bank account's the same yeah
yeah your marriage is the same
yeah your kids are the same except they
miss dad tonight because they just had
their routine right exactly
i just paid a babysitter yeah yeah so
walk people through what that gap in
your soul feels like
yeah the first few times that it's uh
it's
it's pretty crazy you feel like you're
supposed to
you're supposed to feel fulfilled and
not like it's not like it's not a great
experience it was amazing
it was it was awesome but
yeah it ends right it's 23 hours of your
day left
right yeah and uh i've now come to
to recognize that that's the cycle that
you get the high it's a camp high that's
what it is it's a campaign
okay and you know it's fleeting and i've
had number one
songs on the radio and next week
somebody else has a number one song on
the radio like it doesn't last
and uh yeah the first few times of that
are
devastating because is it because of the
expectation
you're caught off guard by it well it's
because you spend your whole like when
you're a kid i'm nine years old drawing
you know drawing stages on in you know
in my notebooks and
that's all i think about and so when you
do it and you realize that's it
oh that's it that's it that's it
you know i've heard you know one of uh
somebody says
someone must say of shakespeare even if
beethoven
is this all yeah you know if that's
if that's the end goal your
accomplishment like you're never gonna
you're never gonna get it jeff bezos
cannot get enough money he has more
money than anyone in the history of the
world
of earth of entire history and it's
still not enough
he's got a new plan for the next thing
right yeah
because if that's what defines you
you're out you're out of luck
so when you when you are sitting at home
listening to this or you're
driving down the road and you think whoa
okay so this guy played carnegie hall
planned his whole life to get here
got there it's awesome
paid his debts off is it is
by all metrics because your daughters
are incredible he's a good dad
um good husband well respected in the
industry
that didn't put appeared at the end of
the sentence for andy right then i'm i'm
backing out thinking
i'm a soccer mom i'm shuttling kids
around town if i could just fill in the
blank if i could just do this
what do you tell folks as an artist
because i i
mental health folks do their thing and
they use science and these
i think the beauty of art is it gets in
the soul through the back door
and it unwinds people in a way that you
feel it here and i think that's
that one of the great tragedies of our
times we've just sucked the artistry out
of so much stuff
right um it's content as it i mean
it's it's the marrow of these bones
right so
what would you tell somebody is more
important than
getting on that stage oh man
i love that you asked that i so now my
primary vocation is uh i work at a
record company
in worship music okay and i oversee a
large group of artists
and songwriters and who are 26 thinking
this is going to be 26 forever right
some of them
yeah okay and and my role is to help
them find the best songs
and create the best versions of those
songs to share to people
and i love it and
i talk often you know often
i will say you know when people are
stressed or frustrated or this didn't
work or they're
angry about this or you know legitimate
or not
there are a lot more janitors in the
world than there are full-time musicians
right or part-time musicians you know
most
most people that i'm ever going to run
across in my life
are the lucky few just because they live
in america
because they live in this time of this
you know 2020
little snapshot of history you know like
uh
the biggest way to fight cynicism or
bitterness which is what happens
after that hollowness right after that
night where you
you get the high and then you feel the
hollowness in the hotel room
at the end of the night like what
follows is a choice between bitterness
or gratitude
and that takes intentionality
and it usually also takes community it
takes friends it takes people who can
call you
on it and say hey you know what stop
being um
you know i need to figure out what i'm
saying
[Laughter]
but you know stop being a jerk that was
awesome
yeah congratulations now how do you how
do you keep being a good dad how can you
live in the gratitude now what what do
you do with that
you know it's not what next but it's
what do you do that you've done that how
can you how does this enable you to
serve your community better how does
this enable you to be
to love your wife better to um to be a
better neighbor better friend and so
um i think gratitude and community are
really
the antidotes for that and
that's fascinating because i think the
tendency i have is to say
well if if a stage isn't going to help
if being a good husband isn't going to
make me feel whole then
why try and it's both and right it's
it's cool to be really good at your
craft
and be well respected in your industry
and
to recognize that's fleeting and this
doesn't define all of you right yeah
i'll say this like when i've stopped i
stopped playing music for a living like
chasing that like
i now know without beyond a shadow of a
doubt that i am not going to be a major
star as a musician okay
because i'm a certain age i've moved
into a different phase of it
i still play a lot of music around town
and work on records and
write songs and it's so much more fun
for me now
because yeah i've put all the time into
it so i'm i'm decent at what i do
he's really really good uh
you're i mean it's nice to be able he
plays fenders and
gibson's that's all i'm gonna say
but it's nice to like to not have the
pressure of it just
like you just enjoy it right it's as fun
as it was when i was 13.
because it's i'm doing it because i love
doing it and i and
i get to learn about myself and i get to
i get to write songs that serve
my community right now um you know i
don't put out a ton of records anymore
it's they used to be every year now
they're every five years yeah
um but my my oldest daughter is 16
my next is 14 like my kids are gonna
leave my house soon so
everything i've been writing a little
this last season this next project that
i'll put out
they're all songs for them for when they
don't live with me anymore this is what
i have to say to you
if you can't get me on the phone you can
find me on spotify this is where i'm
going to leave you
little messages and bottles of what i
have to what i what i want to say to you
and it's
and it's that god loves you pretty much
that's it
here's here's a bunch of different ways
and a bunch of different rhymes to tell
you
that god loves you and
i'm having so much fun doing it there's
so much freedom in it because i'm
literally writing all these songs for
three people
and um but i think i've told you this
i got a copy of your last new record
and i was it was 4 30 in the morning and
i was heading to a hunting trip my son's
dead asleep in the back and i put it in
and i moved the speakers up where
they're just in the little
front part of the truck and
it was so good i almost called you
to tell you i'm driving down the highway
in the
pitch black morning crying i need to
know how good this song is and then i
remember thinking
it's 4 48 we're not that good of friends
yet i'm a lot
this is too much even for me and so i
didn't say anything but i remember just
thinking
how does somebody connect this way and
it's almost like cause you got
you've got you're not just creating good
art bro
but you're writing up you're writing a
love letter to your to your babies right
you're
writing a love letter to grandkids
you're never going to meet
um or great grandkids you you may never
know about legacy that's something
totally different
i mean it's not saying that they're good
songs but they're but it's fun to write
them
you know it's it's that's a different
level of i want to connect so that i can
make a bunch of money
or i gotta have a number one the
pressure oh dude the pressure of trying
to
you know and i've done that in in the
artist world but i've done it now i've
been in the business right side of it
for seven years and so that's long
enough to have
tried really hard to make something work
yeah and i know that that's never the
thing that works a
mm-hmm and b it's never fulfilling right
because i'm just chasing the hit
yeah and when you're trying to do the
thing that to show everybody
so that they respond to you and they
respect you and
like man that's that's never your best
it's hollow right it's never your best
work
yeah it's hollow and nobody trusts
nobody believes it
how does it how does it a a a community
here how does it an audience it's
probably better than community
an audience knows they they know they're
not you
instinctively